[Music]
[Music]
as you can probably guess mr coffee is
most certainly gonna fry
and that's only because we outlawed
hanging but six years ago
but he'll still get to enjoy his last
meal of his favorite chatter on this mug
or from this mug
louderwithcrowder.com
he likes it
for as much longer as he has
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
hmm
that's a good uh that's a good uh charge
up sip yeah for hunting pedophiles oh
geez we're on the hunt can we talk about
that
gonna be out in the no no
i tried to help you can i not say that
i'm not sure wait how are you helping me
by softening my hatred for pedophile it
was air quoted paintball are you a map
sympathist no who's going pedo hunting
wheeze going pedo oh jesus yeah yeah i
don't even wear the camouflage i want
them to i want i wanna come they see
to be this guy i wear a pinwheel hat and
short shorts yes yeah yeah i just fell
out dressed like the ricola guy in later
housing golden lady
so
we have a lot to talk about today the
omicron variant is uh now it's leading
to lockdowns so scary in germany
lockdowns for the unvaccinated going
door to door you'd think they'd be more
self-aware but no putting up walls more
more important than that
we've written about this at the website
you can go read the article at
loudoutcrowd.com the entire report from
the cia just to be clear this is not a
conspiracy
there have been uh at least 10
documented cases
of
child sexual assault including as young
as two and six years old
along with a lot of other troubling
revelations from the cia and there will
be no
prosecution
whatsoever none so this is my question
to you we're going to be talking about
this but when people are mad about
americans losing faith in their
institutions
you know i've said this before actually
comedy is similar to
uh punishment in a society in that
um
people's reaction is generally
commensurate with
the helplessness of the target so if
you're telling a joke people go oh wait
a second you're telling a joke about a
make-a-wish kid okay this we don't know
if we're gonna go with you here same
thing with gang on gang violence people
say okay well gang on gang violence a
little different they're both shooting
at each other however
a child who is the victim of a sexual
predator who is raped the victim of
sexual assault
everyone is on board with the harshest
punishment possible however
what do you do
when the people in charge of prosecuting
and administering punishment are the
people committing these crimes that's
what's happening with the cia right now
this is not a conspiracy you can read
the entire report i want to be clear
it's evil
evil stuff and i want to spend some time
with it so uh outside of that we'll also
be talking about cuomo
i don't want to kick a guy while he's
down so i'd rather just pivot to stelter
who like i've said is definitely angling
for that 9 p.m
he's easy to catch too yeah his chance
when i wish upon a doughnut all right
before that
we have gerald a here how are you i am
well how are you i'm okay i'm doing all
right nice yeah you know that's good
we need like a a special like pedo
change my mind shirt yeah we do yeah
you're gonna die yeah you don't doubt me
for pedophiles change my mind and people
just walk past me like
i'm not gonna
the greatest security threat would be
getting cat called just yeah yeah
i agree with that you'd get to meet
kevin spacey yes exactly
hey listen don't you know the harm
you're doing destigmatize maps i didn't
write the rules i just play by them stop
it uh
quarter black or not at all black yeah
they're just some totally white guy here
yes that's according to the little white
guy well the man doesn't help how are
you oh you know i'm doing good i'm doing
good i'm feeling uh good no sickle cell
not today at least okay well that's good
well you know what day's not over we
don't need you leaving the saint jude's
because we do not have comp for that
long and
he is going to be performing uh january
15th in reading california at the civic
auditorium
the quickest man on his feet that i know
dave landau ahoy i'm good how about you
well i'm good i feel bad that you're
going to have to be in california again
well we got a lot of fans there yeah
because they're tired of all the i'm
going to say it bs oh
jeez all right
before i move on look this is important
uh we are is our last show next tuesday
the tuesday after
i will tuesday afternoon tuesday
afternoon our last show is a tuesday
after next
and that show is going to be a little
bit different it's going to be four
hours of wholesome
santa claus with children live broadcast
i think you can maybe guess who will be
uh portraying santa claus but we have
kids we'll be giving them
finding some meaty families in the texas
area
and the parents are going to be giving
us all this information
on the children so we can make it a
magical experience that's our last show
on that tuesday but if you do not see
this show
and we don't let you know when our last
show is like two tuesdays from now make
sure you just go to rumble or mug club
we are available monday through thursday
10 a.m eastern we have no idea how long
will be available on youtube especially
as we tear apart this narrative of the
mildly annoying omicron variant
yeah
seriously
we're now at the point where it's ah all
cases that we have thus far have been
very mild fatigue
and uh you know sniffles well it's me
every day
it's me every the zyrtec doesn't get rid
of those two symptoms
we're gonna shut we're gonna ask people
for their papers we're gonna have
vaccine passports for that now it's not
about your health anymore it's about
control i think we all know that before
we get to any of that
i haven't seen this you have not seen
this no no none of us this is from
explain it quarter black garrett uh the
old days of old gays on tick tock that's
their name that's the channel and
they're really getting into apparently
the holiday spirit yeah okay i've not
seen this all right the three of us have
not let's see it i have not seen it
hey they're having good fun
[Applause]
oh no where is this going
what a bright time is right time to rock
the night away okay jingle bell time is
a swell time to go riding in a one horse
sleigh
i love how there's one ripped old guy
who's clearly on growth hormone
all right i did not expect that voice by
that old black man
i didn't either
i don't know like a celo green effect
you know maybe a little deeper what a
bright time it's a light times like whoa
a black ethyl merman it's probably the
least weird thing happening on the
streets of l.a in that moment anyway
yeah
that black guy's just running down the
streets in a german kaiser helmet going
clang clang clang like the trolley ding
ding ding with my bell
like do we need a permit for this no
this is just a tuesday i have no problem
honestly the funny thing is that is
positively tame that it was fine i
guarantee if you sent that old gay black
man
were there two there was one black guy
token gay black guy in the outfit token
gay mrs claus yeah if you sent them to
the buzzfeed homepage like well that's a
little severe
yeah that was tasteful yeah it was
that's what i like to call it yes was
that one guys it was his final wish that
santa he looked a little thin yeah yeah
this might be his last just like can we
dance in the street here's my grown-up
list my grown-up christmas list it's
lyle
wish granted oh
i mean let's be honest they survived the
80s that's pretty impressive that is
pretty impressive yeah yeah she's going
to get him again though so how long do
you think it took to edit out stelter
from that oh oh he was just on the side
no guys you got to do it like this he
couldn't keep up with the aerobics they
got aisle images
i'll sing harmony what up right huh oh
boy
i'm going to need to get in shape if i'm
taking over cuomo's 9 p.m slot oxygen
super straight rectum damn near killed
him
so and uh we'll get to more cia uh chris
cuomo was fired from cnn now not put on
temporary
no uh are league upset about this or
according to the victim's attorney
deborah katz this may involve sexual
misconduct yeah that's the reason
for him being fired so look i don't i i
i know he he's
he lied a lot fredo got whacked but
here's yeah i really you know i'm
uncomfortable with kicking a guy while
he's down really yes really i am even in
this yeah i absolutely am so instead i
would rather punch the inflatable
stelter that
comes back up that is true because like
i said before i said watch for it he is
going to throw chris cuomo under the bus
yeah and he wants that slot well brian
stelter
weighed in
now there is one part of the statement
jim that we don't know anything about
just to be completely transparent with
the audience it says there's additional
information that also came to light
sometime this week
we don't know what that is i've asked
there's no answers coming on what that
could be what we do know is that cuomo
was terminated earlier today and brian
do we know when this new information uh
might be brought uh out out to the
public and and will have a sense as to
what this additional information was
and i don't know actually if it ever
will i think that's very much unclear i
think this may be a situation jim just
drawing on my ears as a media reporter
this may be a situation uh where it was
death by a thousand cuts
yes death by a thousand cuts as opposed
to stelter's upcoming
biopic death by a thousand pizzas
let us pray
in silence
[Applause]
one could drink climbing thomas straight
his face hurts
and where is his glasses he can't see
without his glasses
put his glasses on
put on his glasses
[Music]
must have been a lot of bees yes he
needs his glasses i thought it'd be
death by a thousand something else that
starts with p yes uh uh paninis yes yes
definitely a thousand subs big 12-inch
paninis yes hoagies big
black 12-inch paninis
honestly though people will get mad at
this
screw that guy stealth i mean we all
have to get we don't have to get on a
treadmill and die i can hear him growing
this is your job to be on camera for
crying out loud every time i see him
yeah he's large it's pretty it's pretty
bad i thought he was going to be a
bigger fan of the sausage
yeah
he gets the old meat lovers oh he's
loving meat lovers pizza without the
pizza yeah i thought the pepperoni was
going to be on the eyes to say the
boatman though just you just close his
eyes and like coins you put on yeah
by the way anna klumsky in the my girl
thing i just realized she's uh really
dressed down for her best friend's
funeral she really is really a low-rend
piece of trash yeah actually
like she choose what were sweatpants not
available yeah it's great it's only your
best friend that you got killed by bees
yeah you were the one who killed him
maybe bring his glasses you knew he
wasn't gonna have them by the way he was
looking a little sickly and you did
blood brothers with a tin can you might
want to get yourself checked yeah mm-hmm
right yeah because the good son probably
did not have a gl good good blood
profile no no yeah a little hemoglobin
uh being off there have you seen him now
you don't want to no i have i mean i
have seen him but you don't want to be
here you don't want to share a needle if
you have to you know what comment below
you have to be macaulay culkin circa
today
or brian stelter for the rest of your
life it's a freaky friday situation
that's a tough one who do you pick is
there a culinary call
he's cleaned up yeah and he's okay he's
got painted nails he's a cool guy i
don't know yeah he's got brothers that
are in decent movies yeah i assume it's
because of drugs so that he's so white
and wiery yeah well then maybe delta
should try himself some coke if
stelter's a bulldog mccullough culkin's
like an old airedale terrier yeah
that guy could use a heroin addiction
yeah yeah
can we swap i'm sorry am i allowed to
say that it doesn't stealth or work in
media can someone get that guy some
colombian gold maybe that was standard
maybe a tapeworm or something i mean i
feel like he hangs out at a lot of bars
where there's drugs available can
someone just bottle up some mexican tap
water put it in an evian bottle and
serve it to him
like his quarterly treatments
all right so here's another one uh santa
inc is this new show on hbo with uh with
seth rogen and sarah silverman have you
watched this at all i didn't know no
santa
yeah
so they're ramping up their efforts on
christmas here and uh this is santa and
it has the lowest audience score that
i've ever seen in rotten tomatoes
oh wow no critics scores yet because
they just said well we just can't
compete
[Laughter]
um
and then i do have looks
yeah our work is done for us they
already gave it three i watched four
episodes so before we get to that uh
let's watch the tr a lot of people are
upset about it of course seth rogen and
sarah silverman are saying the only
reason people are upset is that they are
white supremacists
one does that's just because my comedy's
gotten really lazy since the pandemic
nobody wants to watch a 50 year old dude
smoke weed
no it's true yeah i'm depressed about it
again
so let's watch the trailer now and see
why everyone is upset with these folks
in hollywood taking aim at christmas
when you're a kid there's only one day a
year more special than any other day
and that day is christmas
and we are the magic behind that day
so let's get these [ __ ] kids some
[ __ ] presents uh go on the avenue
yeah
kids movie
say f word
biz laughs golly he's jolly our own
santa claus
hey merry christmas whoa
you're on my naughty list
[Music]
good news sir more american kids believe
in you than they do in vaccines or the
holocaust that's great i mean
disheartening for america but great for
us oh
wise advice from a canadian i'm here
from the north full times have you
decided who will succeed you with santa
claus subtext santa's old and knocking
on death's door you
uh i mean uh that good good question
i'll give it some serious thought ha ha
ho ho bye
there have been many santa clauses
throughout history some were loved
others loathed but the position of santa
has mostly been a white man's game
oh boy yes [ __ ] crazy things have got
to change no they don't it's not crazy
you're purple
get rid of my porn
i want to be the next santa if this is
your dream you have to at least make
your case you gotta get intimate with
that jolly [ __ ] i know you're right but
do you really have to call me [ __ ]
every time you say something yes [ __ ]
because it's empowering to call you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i would hunt that deer
santa and the board i wouldn't even hunt
it i'd run it over with my car
play golf and leave it alive yeah smoke
cigars
say things like don't ever marry your
mistress
just so you know the women of the north
pole make fun of one of you i don't even
get these jokes whose it is
maybe i'm just stupid but i don't get
these jokes go out with these guys you
know shoot the [ __ ] you shot shoot shots
oh it's my favorite christmas song it's
a great song really
this is where there's a mismatch between
the enthusiasm of the song and the
boring content
i'll be named successor die trying
well this is a show this isn't a movie
yeah it's like
this
in two hours this is full on the show
last night
well
what all right no you go no you go ahead
know i'm just saying what's the plot uh
it's the plot as she wants to be the new
santa because unfortunately old white
men have played santa and then and that
needs to change
just wanted to see yeah so now a little
jewish
i hope i've briefed you you have i just
wanted to make sure i had that correct
and i yeah i don't know i started
getting a migraine yeah well the
comments have been turned off on the on
the trailer so that's a really good sign
yeah
yeah
and you can't see the dislikes yeah and
just keep in mind this is the reason on
youtube dislikes are no longer publicly
available hey you don't see any
independent independent content creators
saying do away with dislikes it's hbo
it's abc it's a viacom it's nbc
universal by the way people we've all
been in some sort of litigation with at
some point in time
just to be clear it gives us a leg up
because we have the power of you right
now watching just like snopes having to
refact check their fact check and the
fact in the check and the fact that
speaking
smash that like button smash the like
button if you're watching to let us know
that you'll go over there and uh
well smash the dislike button here's the
thing
they get to see yeah they get to see it
we don't get to see it publicly but deep
down they know
it's a message straight to them and this
is my issue with it look first off i
don't know why everything has to be
you're a comedian yeah i'm a comedian
with i understand that being subversive
that taking topics and sort of switching
them around
why do we have to do that with something
that's designed to be wholesome for kids
with christmas and look let me just let
me just
sort of present a hypothetical situation
here if i may the reason this rubs
people the wrong way is first off when
you watch this i've watched four
episodes
they revile christmas the disdain for
christmas is very very clear it's not
done with love it's not done with a wink
and a nod if you look at the classics
that people love a christmas story very
funny yeah silent night deadly night yes
precisely black christmas
no but christmas vacation these are
still funny films christmas vacation is
getting a re-release but it's a love
letter to christmas but look
these
okay how would you feel what would you
think if a bunch of gentiles made a film
about hanukkah and took a steaming dump
on everything that it was you think that
would go over well these are people who
know nothing about christmas who don't
celebrate christmas sarah silverman
sarah silverman seth rogen and by the
way he co-produces with evan goldberg
this guy who did pineapple express and i
don't know sausage party his big claim
to fame is knowing seth rogen in high
school well by the way his wife writes
an episode of this series
hey i know seth rogen from high school
hey sweetheart you can be a professional
comedy writer and hbo just said
sounds great signed off on it
good to go this is the incestuous it's
such an incestuous
gene pool in hollywood it's almost the
cia or royal family well and i think
they totally missed about like three
percent obviously right what we want is
more stuff like home alone and christmas
vacation like we want stuff that throws
back to a time when we didn't have to
worry about you trying to say santa has
to be non-white and not a rematch
even exactly not just a remake not
something lazy but something fun like
something that is like i don't want the
woke crap that i have to deal with in
every other part of my life please think
about this
bad santa it's a raunchy movie it's an
adult movie it's it's funny movie but it
still has reverence for and it has heart
and the whole idea it has heart this has
no heart this is just so lazy evil
scrooge is a very dark you know hey
comment you guys let me know yeah i've
experienced that most most women don't
like scrooge because they find it a
little bit dark my wife doesn't that's
pretty dark uh a lot of women are like
ah that's not but i i know a lot of guys
like it that's my favorite scrooge i
would have to put that right up there if
not number one it's interchangeable but
that's pretty dark that and christmas
vacation yeah definitely mine mine would
be that mine would be christmas uh
christmas story that's nice i i disagree
but well that's you can be wrong i'd
rather i'd rather watch this thing
definitely die hard not a christmas
story no i'd rather watch i'd rather
watch my my favorite hey you know what
you better watch your tongue
watch your mouth
what you're about to cross some lines
i visited the christmas story museum in
indiana well it was right next to the
dillinger escape museum and they were
both basically just two picture frames
in a lamp
well there's you can actually go to the
house in cleveland yeah i know but i
don't want to bother though you don't
want to go in that neighborhood no it's
like oh look at the story right the
house is in cleveland it took place in
indiana no i understand that i'm just
saying i didn't know it was cleveland
yeah it's in cleveland that's right well
now you know so plan your big trip yeah
so i lived there that's one stop i
didn't yeah try and plan your big trip
between visits to branson yeah you lived
in the christmas story house i did
pretty much it was an airbnb that's how
you shut your tooth out
by the way you can follow us on
instagram too just so you know where we
do uh non uh non-youtube stuff for as
long as they allow me to be there right
uh we'll have some contests going on
there so germany right now uh has just
imposed well you know what first off can
we show the new york clip so new york
city just announced de blasio this
morning in new york city that they are
now uh
imposing what are they doing is it
passports for all unvaccinated
in new york city it's for unvaccinated
for all on yeah let's let's show the
clip from mayor de blasio
he says it okay let's bring up the clip
from mayor de blasio we in new york city
have decided to
use a preemptive strike to really do
something bold to stop
the further growth of covid and the
dangers it's causing to all of us so
as of today we're going to announce a
first in the nation measure our health
commissioner will announce the
vaccine-made vaccine mandate for private
sector employers across the board public
and private sector employers i thought
it was only going to be 100 employees or
more remember this vaccine mandate as of
december 27th we're going to need some
other measures as well to really focus
on maximizing vaccination quickly so we
can get ahead of omicron and all the
other challenges we're facing right now
yeah and what's really scary about that
we'll go back to the omicron variant in
a second but think about this kids five
to eleven yeah
have to have at least one shot to enter
business no no absolutely go [ __ ]
yourself i am so sorry for saying that
listen i apologize right now
that's evil yeah yeah it is yeah no
absolutely not do you want to clean up
the city tell him to have his daughter
stop riding the train with her coochie
house yeah what's up while they're at it
clean up gerald's mouth i don't know
right
it was a visceral reaction someone get
them the double meant twins in here i
apologize no you're absolutely right
that is absolutely evil you're not
reporting
you are forcing children to be that this
is not science and by the way this is
all done under the guise of what the
omicron variant the omicron variant the
omicron variant we have to be afraid of
the omicron variant well guess what
you're not following the science so this
is new york now but they're following
the lead of places like let me just
clarify one thing here
this is why it matters when we point to
europe or we point to australia do you
doubt for a second
genuine question you guys can comment
do you doubt for a second that if there
weren't republicans or conservatives or
liberty-loving americans standing in the
way
that democrats right now in this country
wouldn't have us do exactly what europe
and australia has done
if they had their way unfettered
europe would be us we would be australia
do you doubt that for a second i just
want to make that clear because guess
what they're doing in germany
they act up again those germans better
keep your eye on those folks uh now
they're imposing major restrictions
on anyone in their population who's
unvaccinated i think we have a clip of
of uh prime minister port grein merkel
so uh some other new german guidelines
include for people who are listening on
audio we had subtitles a train ride uh
unvaccinate unvaccinated people they'll
be limited to meetings with their own
household and only to other people you
will not ask questions
right and we actually have some
disturbing uh footage of course they're
people this isn't the first time of
german authorities uh going door-to-door
looking for the unvaccinated
[Applause]
well i guess we can't blame him it's
just the germans preserving their
traditions and culture i guess so oh
they had to get one shot or the other
yep oh my gosh
six million unvaccinated just to be uh i
think uh they'll say six million but we
both know it'll be closer to six hundred
thousand i don't know what i don't agree
with that just stop
nine so we joke about this but here i
spoke about this with george dr jordan
peterson um the nazis keep in mind they
didn't just come in and say look we are
going to go door to door because we
don't hey everybody we don't like jews
right right no if you have the problem
we see jews people didn't say oh yeah
let's get rid of that's not how it
happened what did they do they began to
drive a wedge through a multitude
of ways of course but a big one they've
always used infectious diseases to other
people and i don't mean other people and
that you don't uh provide a racially
segregated safe space at mizzou i mean
othering people in the sense that you
make them seem
dirty filthy subhuman people who should
not be a part of society the nazis did
label juice disease with typhus lice all
this as an excuse to go door to door and
persecute them and create ghettos a huge
precursor was we had look we we can't
stop the fact that they're dirty these
humans are dead do you want to get dirty
like the unit right no so one of the
things they did they dehumanized them
and they said they are not doing their
part for germany
listen to this this might sound familiar
they are the reason that our economy is
not recovering as fast as it could right
does that sound familiar to anybody do
you understand why that freaks us out
when we hear the government saying oh
it's the unvaccinated if if you're not
for them you're talking about the jews
right yeah that's the reason the economy
is not recovering well that's what
that's what your guy said right but
you're saying charlie check what does
they say no well it's pretty much we
stole your line but who's v front line
well the united states stole your line
we just replaced jews with unvaccinated
right wait wait so the jews now in the
united states has a reason for no
economic recovery you see i think you're
hearing what you want to hear yes yeah
so but that's not what i'm saying what
are you saying why is the economy in z
chasing it's uh it's because of the
unvaccinated according to the us
government oh okay so i understand so
now they're saying unvaccinated
ring fink
no no no no no no no
blue eyes yes it's unvaccinated i don't
know what i said you have
you see i thought this was gonna go
differently
how many unvaccinated does it take to
screw in his a light bulb oh boy i'm not
going to finish that yeah so
it's always been health though health
has always been the thing they use
always been healthy it controls society
so just if you ever question if we're
getting dumber we are we're going
backwards well it's not here's something
else it's not only health it's
your individual health right or someone
else affecting everybody else's health
it's not really about individual health
it's always under the guise of hey the
jews are going to affect
all of your all of your all your health
everything right right hey the
unvaccinated are going to affect the
health of everybody well hold on a
second wait a second how does my health
affect you if you're vaccinated well
because i could still get it yeah well i
guess then the vaccine doesn't work well
but no i'm if i'm vaccinated there's
very little chance that i end up sick or
in the hospital well then you shouldn't
care that i'm unvaccinated but you have
to get vaccinated why because i could
get it i would we're a culture that
picks sexual partners by swiping right
on a phone
think about that yes like and all of a
sudden we care about health right where
have you been the last 20 years for
crying out loud brian stelter
i was trying to think uh ryan stelter is
it brian henry ryan brian stelter brian
who's the stelter's orchestra do you
have a mental like thing i just totally
forgot the point is he looks a toilet
seat to prepare for the show absolutely
and by the way listen you you don't
assume i'm getting my stilters fixed i
really are it's hard
don't assume that the germans were any
more likely to do this than any culture
well they weren't assume a little
they're not no no they weren't they
maybe were willing to go to war and
start some stuff in europe they've done
that several dozen times
but don't assume that you've got to
understand that if the government has
its way in these situations they will
turn you into the person that you think
is the worst person on the planet and
you won't even know it german citizens
didn't necessarily know it at the time
that's a good point you know what they
say about assumptions they make an ass
out of you and we must kill the utensils
oh well that's the last part i don't
think that's what they say that is not
right preserving our culture people
listen to prime minister pork rind
that is a handsome woman that is a
handsome woman boy
devilishly ugh
if anybody could use a shower dashing
[Laughter]
so uh police and health officials and i
want to get to the science here before
we get to the cia raping kids sorry what
i'm just laughing at the word dashing
that grotesque woman yes
i'm grotesquely hot yes yes yes
obviously that's what you meant yes yeah
health it's just dustingly hot healthy
how dare you fat hot yes gag reflex
inducingly yeah attractive yes and
beautiful and brave yes so politicians
and health officials they've been
fear-mongering over the latest
and by the before we get to this this is
something right now right people are
saying well we don't really know at
least they were saying it last week now
that now the jig is up people like okay
omicron not nearly as deadly but i'm
going to show you some clips as to how
they tried to fear monger to control you
however i asked this question
i don't know what two three maybe three
four months ago then another two three
months ago
knowing what we know about viruses
and seeing what we are seeing now with
the omicron variant
i keep wanting to say oh micron but they
always make it hard for you to i always
say corp omni corporation yeah like
robocop yeah all i see is omnicorp we're
gonna be selling nuke yeah so um with
the omicron variant we now know
that it is definitively
less deadly is what we're seeing from
all these cases so far yes one more
communicable less deadly and i said
before that's the way viruses tend to
mutate not always but nearly always
throughout history and my question was
the delta variant i said now we hear
everyone talking about how much more
transmissible this is communicable this
is and i'm i'm not at all denying that i
actually believe that emphatically that
that is true but i was saying
why have they stopped talking about it
being more deadly meaning you're more
likely to catch it but on a
pound-for-pound basis are you less
likely to die from it the media just
went silent those numbers don't really
exist if you go to the cdc these are
obfuscated but let's do let's just do a
thought exercise i believe the first one
they now call the alpha variant if i'm
not mistaken alpha variant okay we know
that that had a certain percentage of
you know how transmissible it was okay
versus uh the mortality rate we
understood we had those numbers now with
the omicron we know that's very very
transmissible and all the cases thus far
have been mild i don't know that there's
been a single death from the uh omicron
variant as of right now we're not seeing
any so certainly not in the united
states uh look i don't want to misspeak
very very few yeah so we have that we go
okay we went from alpha to this
and it's less deadly well there's that
in intermediate step right just look at
the evolution of man the stre that's the
shell epicus of the step why don't we
have the details
how deadly was a delta variant
because that matters if we're talking
about locking down a huge sector of
society if people who aren't in at-risk
categories are at less risk than the
first wave all of that is relevant and
when people say follow the science i say
i i can't find it all references are
available at lateralpad.com so uh
politicians health officials of course
have been trying to push fear on the
omicron variant don't take my word for
it a lot of whether or not we're headed
into a bleak or bleaker winter is really
going to depend upon what we do
and i think what you're seeing is just
the manifestation of what we've been
talking about why it is so important
for people to get vaccinated and for
those who are fully vaccinated to get
boosted we have missed the chance to be
at a much less
vaccination across the country
for all those reasons of misinformation
that people have heard we've not done
what we should have done to protect
ourselves if if omicron is one more
wake-up call then let's wake up richard
if you're not vaccinated i'm a crime i'm
still worried about the new variant get
your booster
if you aren't fact snails get that shot
go get that first shot he's saying
booster that's how they feed him they
put him in a booster seat and he eats
his cheerios with his face
i can't get him in i want to pause real
quick is it just meteors biden's
former vice president biden it seems
like his hair is thinning do we do we
have a picture there a screenshot of
that let's let me see do you have a
screenshot of that yeah overlay see one
can you bring it up no no not that one
no not that one not that one uh that's
that's that's
let me see another one yeah is his hair
thinning no no that's what that's when
he was a young man with a head full of
hair let's i mean what you just saw in
that video
yeah maybe it's just me
uh did you also notice that he's wearing
a pinstripe suit and much larger than
that like he's a bouncer like a mafia
hitman yeah or gomez adams i think that
he they're just putting like a suit and
he sticks his head in it
like the background is fake
in the army yeah i think he's just
putting his head through a circle yes
it's like a ripped ton out of the
president like at sea world when you put
it in the submarine helmet yeah take a
picture it did not look authentic at all
no it did not you mean former president
joe biden doesn't look authentic he's
really laying in bed so this yeah yeah
they actually set it on him
that's what was going on with his hair
his hair was fanning because
i actually thanks they got it to me here
from mission control uh no omnicron is
only causing mild illness and has
resulted thus far in zero that's great
oh that's already in cnn that is great
news here's some news fantastic careful
hey everyone out there who's really
bought into this uh wholesale on the um
i keep honest now i'm saying omnicron
you son of a [ __ ] i'm the corp
no no it's gonna wait
i got my shelters mixed up now i'm gonna
get my variants mixed up think about
this though if we call it omnicore if we
can say anything we want because we're
talking about omni that's that's
absolutely true
there we go let's put the difference all
right omnicron omnicron
um watch it's gonna be pulled out of
context you couldn't even say the name
of the disease really yeah well you mean
shut up we did it on purpose so um it's
called a joke here's something i want
you to by the way i hope you have your
mouth guard in for people who bought
into this because this tin can i'm about
to kick might hit you in the teeth um we
don't have all of the vaccine daddy yet
but i started reading some stories and
then put it together
um
it seems thus far that the vaccine has
no effect with the omnicron
variant is that the actual name no no
i've forgotten no yeah omicron oh
i don't care not on the eye
am i yeah but i'm gonna say omnicron i
added the n
so in the in the united states
i hate first of all first case of
omicron variant autobots
first case in san francisco
first united states case first wow fully
vaccinated second case in california
fully vaccinated other states where the
first documented case of the omicron
variant were fully vaccinated colorado
massachusetts
new jersey utah nebraska connecticut
wisconsin georgia minnesota
all of the first cases
fully vaccinated two out of three
maryland cases fully vaccinated
washington missouri louisiana's health
departments they don't keep track of all
of these but you know what the hipaa
laws actually would allow for this
information to be public they've decided
they don't want to
kind of like the pfizer documents will
come out within the next 50 years why
right
[Laughter]
it takes
copies yeah why did you ask it's just
kind of like when joe biden says this is
a come on this bill isn't going to cost
you a dime 1.5 trillion how'd you say to
the exact letter it's like the milk
expiration date we know 1.5 trillion
doesn't cost us anything how did pfizer
say hey we can't have these documents to
you right now but hold on a second i
think we can get it to you let me uh
carry the one 50 years that's the best i
can do
but still relevant information
so let's just let's go abroad because we
don't want to be nationalistic
that's japanese for japan
two of the three confirmed cases there
fully vaccinated
no vaccine data is available for the
second confirmed case the uk more than
half of the confirmed omni uh um omicron
omnicore cases were double vaxxed
israel's on you at this point are you
double x
israel 11 cases
they had 11 cases in israel seven fully
vaccinated six of the patients even had
received their booster shot which also
means in israel fully vaccinated now it
doesn't yeah because you're not fully
vaccinated until you have the third
right yeah well the fourth is coming out
and this yeah that's exactly it now
they're considering a fourth shot so my
point here is this if you guys are now
willing we've been through this
experiment so many times yeah
we had two weeks to flatten the curve
okay
then we turned out that's going to be
two years effectively right there's it's
effectively been two years i know not
everyone's been in full lockdown if
you're if you're in new york basically
unless you have a passport then it
became all right masks but no masks and
then masks and then it became okay
vaccines are occurred then it became
vaccine mandates now it's becoming
vaccine passports in europe they're
actually basically eliminated
unvaccinated people from the population
at large
and we've gone through okay the first
variant then the delta variant which
again it's odd that we don't have the
data there as far as the mortality rate
but we have we understand it's more
transmissible
and now you have a huge portion of
americans who are still willing to give
up their liberty
for a variant that is significantly less
lethal that has had no deaths and the
significant majority at least almost all
of the first cases and then they stopped
keeping track a huge portion of these
cases are fully vaccinated so even if
you give up your liberty at this point
it won't help you anyway this shows you
that it's not only not about health with
those in power it's about control and it
shows you that many americans who are
following at this point
don't care about health it's about a
willingness to be controlled as long as
it's the right people doing the
controlling because that's how they gain
political power yeah wouldn't it be a
good thing though if we found out that
omicron was very transmissible but had
mild symptoms like they're talking about
soreness and very very very mild stuff
now it's something natural immunity
exactly it was just like wouldn't you
have omicron parties at that point yes
isn't that the time where you're like
hey throw off all the restrictions
unvaccinated you guys get the run of the
place go get it well this is why he's
joy remember we had the first variant
and then it was replaced i think it was
98 percent right we're delta variant at
by a certain point i read numbers as low
as 94 and i read numbers as high as 99.
yeah reference is available a lot of
credit.com let's take a middle let's say
96 basically the original variant was
replaced with the delta variant which
effectively killed out the original
variant most people getting the delta
alpha now if this is the main variant
this is exactly what you would hope
if you could write out jurassic park the
best case scenario right the best case
scenario for some kind of a
post-apocalyptic scenario
post-apocalyptic film you would
fast-forward time-lapse six months oh
then the virus mutated to a point where
it didn't kill anybody and get into the
sniffles fantastic problem solved
barely even turned into a zombie this is
how you solve world war z this is like
oh okay nobody's turning into zombies
anymore you just got a running knife the
guy just has a little bit of foam in his
mouth you dab it like it's joe biden you
know at the dinner table 28 days later
everything's good yeah and then he put
him on a leash oh hey more of a harness
yeah what was a little bit out of now i
just spiked to the ground in that movie
in world war z no no no one eight days
later oh that's right that's right that
was a rough one okay
now we have to get the sorry that'll be
the part i understood
this point is this you couldn't pray for
something better than a variant that
would replace previous variants because
it's more transmissible right yes and
significantly less lethal not even
significantly less lethal just it's
overall less unpleasant
yeah it's almost like herd immunity
getting something to go no no no almost
like remember when i tried to ask that
question and you accused me of asking a
second question to a certain political
figure which didn't happen senator not
true
what question did you have for rand paul
i know that was last week in my show i
said oh you mean you mean the one that
was ruined for me i'll tell you
you just didn't have the balls to ask it
after my brilliant question oh is that
right what was your point there wait
wait a point no i was just uh the point
is now it's easier than ever to reach
her immunity so go out and lick some
telephone poles
stuck stuck
so this man has no dick
um
ouch well that's a perfect segue because
now we're going to get into the cia
this is the this is so evil i want to be
clear uh if you do have kids watching
and i know that a lot of you do uh you
know we always try and keep the show
like a strong p it's just pg-13 i like
the realm of suggestion you know listen
all of us are flawed but this is a rough
topic because it involves uh the raping
of children and it's happening at the
highest levels of government
so
i would advocate that you not have young
people if you haven't had that talk with
you yet you know it's the it's the birds
and the bees well now it's the the birds
i guess the fuzz and the uh the fuzz
i don't know the birds and the popos
so last week buzzfeed and kudos to them
for doing actual journalism they took a
break from um giant obese fat chicks
painting with their asses and menstrual
blood yeah to do actual journal and
catalysts to do actual journalism and i
appreciate this through a freedom of
information request uh they revealed
over the past 14 years that at least and
these are just the ones that are
undeniable from the cia and their
internal investigation 10 cia
contractors and employees committed sex
crimes involving children
we have this available the whole report
i think it's 75 pages or maybe it's 100
something pages there's a lot of legal
ease in there so you can read the
summary at loudest crowder.com
uh
the allegations in this report are
discussed yes read 100 pages of sexual
abuse and sleep tight well a lot of it
is them saying well there was sexual
abuse but and then couching it be like
but uh this is the best we can do it's
just so
gross so bad one person had sexual
contact with a two-year-old and
six-year-old this is the cia burnham
one purchased three sexual abuse videos
of young girls filmed by their mothers
another
uh viewed more than 1400 kitty
pornography images while on assignment
here's the thing okay
well the most offensive part is the
child sex crimes yeah but also the
idiocy
they didn't even use a vpn while they
were on cia computers
that must mean there is such a lack of
fearing any sort of accountability for
crying out loud while on assignment 1400
you must have not been doing any job
well even if you had to look at it to
make sure you knew what it was don't you
just need to look at one right you're
like i better check the other thirteen
hundred and nine months just to be safe
yes i better check thirteen hundred
labeled taxes unbelievable oh my
goodness and the guy with the
six-year-old discussed twice yeah twice
twice with the six-year-old
so out of that and here's the scariest
part out of the ten instances uh that
are described in the report only one
person was ever charged with anything
yeah
with anything
comment below
do you guys know this story
this this should be catnip for the media
right think about it you've got you've
got this lewd behavior you've got
corruption at the highest levels of
government right erin brockovich
something about fake tits and tap water
yeah this the cia raping children and
sexually assaulting children
and they're not being prosecuted
where are you
where are you
well don't worry stephen i think a few
of them were fired yeah well the rest
that's the thing the rest of the cases
they were sent back to the cia to handle
them internally whatever the hell that
means what yeah and um
according to the insiders the cia
resists criminal prosecution because
this this is a quote
from one of the cia lawyers saying we
can't have these people testify they may
inadvertently be forced to disclose
sources
and methods
well if that's the issue maybe you
shouldn't keep hiring sex offenders
here's here's my point here look think
about this for a second think about this
for a second um people will say well
look you're just this is uh you know
you're just trying to be lewd here
you're trying to to be lascivious
lascivious insidious outrageous but the
point is yes there's pedophilia
everywhere sure there are sick people
everywhere however
they aren't
completely immune from prosecution or
consequences everywhere this right now
think about this for a second someone
who's looking up 1400 images of child
pornography while on assignment let me
ask you this you think they just woke up
head off the pillow and said i finally
got my dream job at the cia i'm finally
going to allow myself that kitty porn
treat yourself or do you think that they
were likely doing this their whole life
because these people are sick who are
incapable of being rehabilitated look at
the recidivism rate of pedophiles it's
disgusting it is just a a sickness that
puts everyone else in danger not like
the unvaccinated pedophiles actually put
other people in danger so let me ask you
this
do you think that it's more likely these
people were engaging this activity
before and the central intelligence
agency
didn't spot any red flags so what does
that tell you that tells you that either
the cia is so incompetent that they
couldn't spot maybe some disturbing
behavior with people who were looking up
thousands of child pornography images
paying for child pornography on cia
computers or devices i don't want to be
misquoted there i don't know if they
were using an iphone ipad or desktop
just to be clear so they are so
incompetent that they serve no purpose
or
they knew it and they recruited them
anyway and protected them anyway until
they got caught either way we're at the
point where the cia serves no functional
purpose again it the punishment needs to
be commensurate with the level of
helplessness of the victim i don't think
that there's any more
i i guess
sort of highly more easily viewable
easily on display grotesquely so a
differential in power than between a
child and a sexual predator i think you
don't just bury those people beneath the
railroad tracks i think you make sure
these people die and you test the
lineage of the rest of them to make sure
it hasn't infected the gene pool just to
be clear yeah that being said this is an
advertisement hey if you're a pedophile
if you're a child rapist
come on work for the cia because well
you'll probably make through our
screening and then if you do engage in
any sex sex while you're here we'll make
sure to cover it up because we don't
want our sources to be revealed if
that's the case then they also serve no
useful purpose this is an example what
do you do when the people in power who
are supposed to prosecute the crimes are
the ones committing the crimes the worst
kind of crimes imaginable yeah i have a
quick question so the cia is basically
saying that people can't testify because
they may inadvertently kind of disclose
methods and procedures right okay what
do you do with spies
are you basically just telling me that
you can't do anything with spies either
because they may inadvertently if they
have to testify in a court if they have
to defend themselves say hey i'm not a
spy for some foreign agency and i've
infiltrated the caa are you saying that
you just fire those guys as well is that
is that what happens i'm pretty sure
that's not you found a way find a way
here yes
well they're changing the cia acronym to
children's irresistible asses
so i think it's fine
but i'll allow it yeah they're opening
it up i think you know that was a reach
but we should but i will allow thank you
i i played it in my head
or not respect i think we know that was
a reach to incl but it works
it does it is more descriptive right now
and by the way this debauchery this
degeneracy doesn't just stop at the cia
to be clear this is one thing i will
thank uh president donald trump for this
i absolutely was not as aware of the
the evil that exists in all of our
intelligence agencies the fbi the cia uh
the dea doj i wasn't aware how pervasive
it was and i do think that donald trump
uh really did shine a light and you know
what yeah jfk also tried to do that to
his credit yep you know i know that he
had jaundice and he was banging
everybody and everyone all of them were
running a train on marilyn monroe not
named ted how did the cia handle that
one
totally
totally one guy i have a dream keep keep
your eyes on that man in the glasses and
that top hat that man looks like
he got me oh i'm seeing a flash seems
like a good day to stand on a balcony
across from that guy who's looking at me
with a gun yep there he is no wait it's
just binoculars he's dressed like mr
cobblepot
so the debauchery isn't just happening
at the cia
i wish i could bring you good news
pentagon security official daniel payne
uh said that workers computers when they
were examined this is what he said the
amount of child porn i see is just
unbelievable i'd like something more
quantifiable than unbelievable yeah
because to me
like i don't know like 1400 is already
unbelievable does he mean like to me one
image yeah child porn yes on a pentagon
computer like can you believe this i
would like to change the quote
the amount of child porn convictions
that we have seen in this agency is
unbelievable yeah that would be better
good point yes i think it's just one of
those
they started selling the pin up calendar
is when it really became an issue
you know i'm sorry i have to make this
lighthearted furious for crying out loud
more of these cia officials would have
gone to prison if they showed up to that
[ __ ] block chris hansen's house yes well
dave they have how you know
it's just the same guy with like an
earpiece and a suit
showing up in ray-bans yeah that's
that's his out he walks it's like hey
have a seat over there for a second wait
a second oh i've got to take this and he
just walks out and it's tackled by the
real kids he's looking he's trying to
use the men in black flasher on him and
he's like that doesn't that's not you're
just hurting
stop
hey is that a is that a bag of subway
no hmm so um
my good friend gave this to me for free
we were just gonna talk uh a 2009 ice
report revealed several pentagon staff
were subscribed to child pornography
sites this is what we all the reference
is available first off uh it's one thing
to be
it's one thing to be a degenerate who
abuses children in which case you
deserve to die
it's another thing to have uh
looked at a couple of images right and
and in which case you you deserve to be
locked up
it's entirely another
to be paying and subscribing for
pornography at a job
involved with our highest national
security offices which from what i'm
seeing the only way they could have
found it
is if they did it in the company
computers
yeah
wow
at work
are all pedophiles [ __ ]
yes i think that is the lesson i don't
know i mean that's i mean it's not the
worst part but it is a layer how dumb
these pedophiles are that's insulting to
people that are [ __ ] yeah that's
true they're they're a lower form than
that okay
i retract that statement yeah i'm kind
of [ __ ] matter of fact i would like
to send out gangs
of [ __ ] people to lynch pedophiles
uh well it'd be good you know yeah
like yeah you know
you're sick
no does anyone else can we hire can we
hire anyone can we hire people people
who maybe uh have difficult uh time
finding employment in the modern world
that's okay i'm digging my whole here
but my point is this
comment below ex-cons what do we do
what do we do and let me ask this on a
personal level do any of you disagree
with the fact that child rapists deserve
the death penalty i used to be not
really pro death penalty i'm super pro
death penalty now oh you don't even have
to pay me i'll kill him yeah well just
what he means he means that he's a
comedian
no yeah no don't talk about our saturday
plans hypothetically if i had
like this guy touched a kid i would
hypothetically yeah shoot him in the
face without feeling remorse yes dave's
like can you fit a body in this trunk i
just bought it i'm trying to buy a new
car here
right
you know for uh i would hypothetically
uh have my popcorn ready for these
people to be strong and quartered yes i
needed to vill yes
the 2012 report confirmed two national
reconnaissance officers admitted to
child molestation and viewing child
pornography let's not forget that
jeffrey epstein himself the trial is
going on you would think that the media
be covering that a little bit more um
that he was cozy with the cia uh right
here i have uh south florida a u.s
attorney for south florida alexandra
acosta said i was told that epstein
belonged to intelligence and to leave it
alone and one of his bodyguards claimed
that epstein sent him to the cia
headquarters saying i didn't know why i
was there but epstein told me that they
would quote take care of me so i don't
know what you do
what do you do when people say oh
there's mistrust mistrust in
institutions okay
let's take the idea that there are
people who you know mistrust the most uh
free fair and safe elections of all time
right and you get furious and you say oh
well look at these people they become
unruly when they don't trust our
institutions okay uh and i understand
that's a pretty big deal if people feel
like their votes don't count or they
were taken away from them yeah
are you going to blame the people for
mistrusting institutions here at the cia
international intelligence agencies when
we have them going completely
unprosecuted for child sex crimes are
you more mad about people not trusting
the institutions or are you furious with
the institutions for allowing this to go
on for decades unfettered i just want to
know do you blame the american people
because you're completely incapable
of seeing those in the swamp in the
political and media elite covering this
up this isn't about some guy having a
sex dungeon in a pizza parlor this is
about an internal investigation
revealing what has been a long-standing
pattern of behavior
of child sexual assault and a
long-standing precedent of
no prosecution no charges no convictions
yeah well two buzzfeed actually said
they started filing these freedom
information requests in i think 2010 or
11. it's been a 10-year process to get
this information out it's like you just
hide it for a decade until the people
who are responsible are gone and then
it's like oh yeah these things went on
but we're the new people here we'll make
sure we make corrections the old people
are gone don't worry about them i mean
we
we wrote a note in that one guy's file
so he'd have a hard time getting a job
next time you know for screwing kids
matter of fact i can find his file right
here oop nope that's just child porn
hold on hold on i can find it let me
close that tab
it's just well you know what i'll email
the file to you research it was research
ten years or as they call it elderly oh
yes aged out over the hump yeah
now to be fair
to be fair we probably should have seen
this coming given the a lot of people
know the super inclusive humans of cia
ad okay yeah from
a recruiting ad from for the cia just a
few months ago yeah
i am a grown man
a cisgender caucasian millennial
i have irritable bowel syndrome
i also think i suffer from micropenis
deformation
but when i tried to show my doctor
he said i'm a pediatrician who let you
in here
so i showed everybody in the waiting
room
and was beaten within an inch of my life
i am a self-diagnosed minor attracted
person
is that a clinical term
well it's a central intelligent agency
it doesn't matter
at the cia
i am free to
unapologetically be myself
and you could be too
join the fight
and see your local recruiter today
oh
hey kid i have some puppies in my van
only the best and brightest yeah well a
very effective ad for them apparently
yes yeah i'm surprised that people that
know this is what is he doing even joe
lewis doesn't like this so you see this
he just jerked that blanket off and he
was like stop talking about pedophiles
all right we'll move on i'd rather smell
my own butt than watch this yeah uh by
the way hey guys look uh what what do i
want them to do i want them to uh
smash it
smash it smash that like button uh and
if we are not available here because of
disclosing cia pedophile relations watch
us on rumble
smash it the way a cia agent
see i didn't finish it
get him he's the pusher
[Laughter]
well gerald's written that you know what
oh you know what kidding i love you this
is uh this is going to be a perfect
segment we're about to go to mug club
only because there's no way we could
ever play no no the game gay or slay uh
and for those who don't know what this
game is uh it's actually uh here's a
clip was it uh token allen of norway
yeah nori nori nori's his rap name his
name was like noriega okay
he was explaining too that in the rap
game this rap game
that uh as you know as in capone as you
all know that uh he says a lot of people
at the top either have to uh do some gay
stuff or some satanic stuff
and we cannot confirm nor deny that we
can confirm or deny some sources that
we'll be talking about in just a second
but here's him saying this
when you platinum and you're getting 50
000 a show i've been there
there's a door that you could walk in
i'm not sure if it's homo or if it's
illuminati i just didn't take that
though i went straight
this is this is this when you get to
when you get to a level of success when
you're getting
30 40 50 000 to show you platinum you're
running across the world there's a
there's three different doors right
there's three different ways to walk
it's to the left
this to the right and then they're
straight to straight as you're on your
own
let's see if you continue this success
young man okay let's see if it was all
about your skills young man let's really
see that okay you went straight to the
right
i'm not sure if that's the hormone [ __ ]
right there
and then this to the left i'm not sure
if there's some sacrifice [ __ ] going on
right there i'm not sure because i went
straight the one thing i was wondering
is who's the designer for his home
because noriega seems to think that all
doors are triangles
all right we're gonna play gay or slay
youtube we can't do this here so you can
piss off
you